have you ever been
afraid on the mat does fear have any
role
do you think for a wrestler
or it must be well i'm sure fear is out
there
and i'm sure that was to my advantage
almost every time
i'm sure in my olympic finals as really
if he had these doubts he probably had
these doubts
and that gave gives me the the edge
and i don't know if i really ever
had fear
but obviously there was points and times
where i
didn't perform as well not many but
a few and if i look back of it look back
at it i don't think it was that
american you know raw raw raw stuff i
think it was
probably the fear of uh not being an
artist
as much you know maybe this guy might be
better than me
uh scientifically and uh
you know you're a scientist i think that
got to me more than anything else
i i said early on that i want to
eliminate
ever having to worry about getting tired
in a match
so i kind of eliminated that so i got
rid of that point
and i do think that in wrestling that is
one of the fears
that a lot of wrestlers have actually
how they feel during the match and and
do they get
are they going to get tired and and is
it going to affect my performance
and as a coach that really was one of
the things i tried to eliminate on all
my athletes
so there wasn't that fear factor but
that fear factor would be
put upon my opponent which would give me
an edge uh but that's not what i needed
as much
i need to just focus make sure that i
was doing the right things
and i needed my team to be focused so i
made sure that for my
mistakes as an athlete or even as a
coach sometimes
that i didn't repeat them uh didn't
repeat them and
if you make a mistake once and then you
could repeat it then it's like
you didn't learn anything
you